what's popping Monster Hunters it's me
Mt and welcome back to the heavy spoiler
show spoilers for Monarch Legacy of
monsters episode 5 because oh my God
wouldn't you know it this video is
actually a breakdown for that episode I
know shocking thought I'd switch things
up this week keep you guys on your toes
so let's just jump on into this Beast
shall we because unlike my mental state
this episode isn't going to break itself
down now is it nope and with the last
episode ending with Kate May canaro and
Shaw being rescued from being permanent
Al and popsicles this episode opening
with a shot of all of them confined
within Monarch holding cells was very
much to be expected and as Monarch keeps
a close eye on each of them to the right
of that jail video feed we can see a
computer screen with the same radiation
visuals that Monarch research agent
Barnes first picked up in her trailer in
the last episode then after the intro
goes for the fifth time we get to
witness Monarch agent Duval begin to
seduce May with the promises of
scientist ific Glory implying that if
May were to cooperate with her May would
be free to name that gigantic soul
sucking snow mole that almost killed her
and her friends after herself because if
you ever got the opportunity to name the
person that tried to kill you why not
just take it however what's particularly
interesting during this moment is that
Duvall seems to not exactly know May's
true name as May is actually carrying
two passports with the name of her
sister Lyra Mato on the other passport
so considering that passports usually
have people's pictures on them I think
the implication here is that Lyra and
may might both have identical faces as
Twins and that may is merely using
Lyra's real passport in order to pass as
Lyra and avoid detection all those times
that we saw May keeping her phone call
short with Lyra was likely due to May
wanting to keep Lyra out of all the
sketchy illegal shenanigans that May's
hacker lifestyle tends to get her in
with her recent runin with those
confidential Monarch files being one of
those worst cas scenarios that may Was
preparing for because if anybody finds
out that may has a twin sister then may
won't be able to be the Incognito ghost
traveler that she wants to be but while
Lyra being May's twin sister has yet to
be seen we do also learn that this Lyra
Matteo is also located on the west coast
of the United States in Tacoma
Washington which could be why we see May
giving Lyra a phone call on that boat
ride while on her way to Alaska and
telling her that she might be coming
home soon but at any rate it definitely
feels like Duvall even saying Lyra's
name seems to have spooked May the hell
out and was likely the chief reason why
may agrees to give Duval a call at the
very end of the episode because while
May's teeth were a chatterin outside
Santa's Alaskan Workshop she revealed
that her sister Lyra was pretty much the
only real immediate family that she had
left that would actually care if she
passed away so not getting Lyra wrapped
up in this whole Monarch situation is
definitely of high importance for Maine
especially since let's be real this
ain't even May's problem all of this is
happening because canaro and his
surprise sister brought all of their
family drama to her comfy Japanese
apartment so she kind of has no real
reason to remain loyal to the messy
Randa family especially now that her own
family has been put in the crosshairs of
the shitty shadowy charlatans over at
Monarch a frustration that may has been
sharing with canaro over these last few
episodes but anyways after this Duval of
course gives an update to assistant
director Verdugo and Tim with Tim then
suggesting that Monarch give the Randa
children a crash course into the family
business rather than you know them like
common criminals but it is actually
agent Duval who recommends to Verdugo
that Monarch let Kate May and canaro go
but keep them on a Long Leash which is
what immediately happens in the
following scene when we see Tim and
Duval dropping the gang off at the
airport in Gnome Alaska with money plane
tickets and government provided cell
phones that definitely haven't been
bugged with trackers whatsoever you can
trust Monarch because why would Monarch
do something like that these are
Christian people they named themselves
Monarch because God is the monarch of
Heaven
I'm kidding but no seriously as soon as
Monarch handed out them phones and may
didn't immediately throw hers away and
suggest that Kate and canaro do the same
I knew that something was up because May
isn't the type to keep an oops we're
sorry cell phone from the Shady friends
of Uncle Sam unless it could somehow
help her in the end because she knows
that these people are definitely
tracking her I mean this is the same
chick who threw her cell phone off of a
boat in order to keep Monarch from
finding her again like someone as TCH
savy as May was not born yesterday but
honestly regardless of whether or not
May is actually trying to betray Kate
and canaro I can definitely see may
eventually working for Monarch by the
end of the series May's skills at Data
Mining and stealth were remarkable
enough to raise agent Duval's eyebrow
after all so I would not be surprised if
Monarch picks this insanely talented
free agent up real quick to join the
squad because as we can see with Tim
over the course of the series Monarch
isn't exactly a bad organization filled
with bad people KO and Bill Randa did
not found Monarch with that intention
they've just evolved into a fearful
monster of a Monster hunting entity an
entity so fearful of another monster
attack that it has begun to grow numb to
the civil liberties of others because
who needs civil liberties not
me a dystopian future is coming for us
all anyway but despite that whole
attempted kidnapping thing which is
minor little thing no big deal Tim
himself is definitely evidence of
monarchs still having good people with
good intentions in it like Tim only
really did that because he appears to
have a deeper awareness than most about
just how devastating this new breed of
titanized Beast could be for the human
race as a whole which is why he snapped
at the idealistic Trio at the airport
telling them to wake the hell up however
if there's one Monarch agent that I do
not trust whatsoever it is of course
agent Duval an agent who is deeply
obsessed with trying to find out exactly
what the Randa and Shaw families know
more so than I feel that agent Verdugo
wants to know because while it may
appear that Duval is was simply working
with Monarch to try to find out what the
gang knows about Bill randa's files you
got to remember that Monarch isn't the
only sketchy well-funded organization on
the market because let's not forget the
historically accurate biopic that
released in the year of our lizard Lord
2021 Godzilla versus Kong and how the
rich over at Apex cybernetics
were the main bad guys of that film that
used trickery to get well- meaning
scientists and Kong himself to lead them
to the radioactive power source from the
hollow Earth because there's a good
chance that Duval could be a double
agent here on behalf of Apex cybernetics
in my opinion and possibly the very
double agent that could actually end up
being responsible for bringing the
hollow Earth to Apex cybernetics
attention in the first place as the
events of Monarch Legacy of monsters
take place in the year 2015 a full nine
years prior to the events of Godzilla
versus Kong like I alluded to in
previous Monarch videos it's appearing
more and more likely that the same
mysterious blue radioactive power source
that was the the focal point of that
movie seems to be informing the plot of
Monarch Legacy of monsters as well as
one of those blue power sources made
another appearance in the frosty Hills
of Alaska and were likely the focus of
Bill and Hiroshi randa's research the
coordinates that canaro uses the son on
the map to decipher at the end of the
episode likely revealed different
Wormhole tunnel locations to the hollow
Earth home of all of the Titans that
Hoshi Randa found keeping those
locations a secret from a trigger happy
Monarch in order to honor his mother
Ko's wishes after KO watched General
Pucket try to blow up Godzilla with a
bunch of nukes but anyways after the
gang convinced May to stay with them
they used their Monarch money to travel
from gnome Alaska back to San Francisco
with the wide shot of the city revealing
the still broken Golden Gate Bridge that
Godzilla walked through in Godzilla 2014
causing the wheels on the bus to stop
going round and round leading Kate to
have immense trauma for the rest of her
life because all of those kids died on
the bus while walking through the
Oakland Airport the gang noticed an add
for a company called strata secure homes
that provides titanium strength bunkers
in the event of a Titan emergence likely
a bit of foreshadowing for something our
protagonists might be needing to use to
protect themselves by a Kaiju by the end
of the series and also I bet you a
million bucks that that rich
Walter Simmons owned one of these bad
boys while he was working on building
Mecca Godzilla and Godzilla versus Kong
but anyways after this Kate then
switches things around for canaro and
introduces him to his father's other
wife Caroline Randa a woman working with
with FEMA as part of their Urban
recovery program after Godzilla's attack
devastated countless homes in the region
a number of missing posters can actually
be seen on a fence as the gang roll up
to Caroline's house and the tall work
friend James mobile then Kate's cool ass
mom Caroline then helps the gang break
into the quarantine Red Zone in order to
access Hiroshi randa's San Francisco
office but on the way to that office the
gang walk past the remains of one of
Kate's favorite coffee shops called
grounds hero which is of course a play
on the term ground zero which is
hilarious considering that San Francisco
was Ground Zero for legendary's new
monsterverse in 2014 with Godzilla's
arrival there actually used to be a
coffee shop named grounds hero in real
life over in Arkansas but that place
closed a little while back but this
Ground Zero in the show is for sure an
accepting one as we can see a pride flag
hanging at the top of the building which
is very fitting for this episode's
reveal that Kate is actually into women
which is honestly super awesome and
relatable because let's face it boobs
Rule and no can tell me otherwise nobody
not you not your mama not your daddy but
what's super not awesome is learning
that ground's hero was actually Ground
Zero for lesbian infidelity I cannot
even believe that we have been following
a cheater of a teacher this entire time
like I know that four boobs are better
than none but my God have some restraint
woman I'm just kidding but this
Revelation definitely serves to continue
this Show's themes of reflective
dualities because while Kate was being
angry and judgmental at her own father
for going on a International world tour
with his penis she was doing her own bit
of sneaking around as well and while
this is obviously not ideal for both of
Kate's partners because cheating hurts
people stop cheating people Jesus Christ
that infidelity might actually end up
being good for Kate's character growth
in the end because Kate definitely knows
how complicated and conflicting the
emotions involved in cheating can
possibly be because it honestly seemed
like Kate cared for both of these women
much like her father Hiroshi cared for
both Caroline and Amo equally but
anyways when we get a look into Kate's
science classroom we can see that Kate
made sure to highlight the achievements
of famous women in science like
astronaut May gson who became the first
African-American woman in space in 1992
Marie curri who became famous for her
groundbreaking work in the field of
radio activity and Joselyn Bell Bernell
who was responsible for detecting the
first radio pulsars in space all the way
back in 1967 and considering how agent
Barnes detects Pulsar type radiation
coming from within the planet itself at
the start of the last episode The
placing of these three important women
of Science in this scene was very much
meant to be a shout out to all the
important women that have made the
science fiction Narrative of the monster
verse possible Kate for sure has the
scientific Spirit of her own
trailblazing grandmother KO and on that
same wall we can see that Kate has her
own maps of the Earth with satellite
type weather data and whatnot on the
sides proving Kate's Claim about her
science class helping her decipher her
father's old maps at his office later on
in the episode but anyways I really
enjoyed how the process of Kate walking
through the ruins of San Francisco also
doubled as a metaphor for Kate dealing
with her past traumas and regrets that
manifested around gday with those
flashbacks becoming stronger and
stronger the more that Kate ventured
through those ruins until she has
another one of her panic attacks that we
saw her suffering through in that first
episode and I especially love how this
metaphor served the overall lesson of
the episode of the only way getting
through one's pains and anxieties is to
actually confront those anxieties and
accept the emotions that come with them
which is why kentaro reveals that he
found a way out right after May advises
Kate to do just that because the only
way out is through and honestly I deeply
enjoy this moment between Kate and may a
whole lot and really do hope that these
two end up together by the end of the
series because they would be
ridiculously good for one another like
they seem to be bonding a whole lot in
this episode and I'm all about it but
anyways that is it for this breakdown of
Monarch Legacy of monsters episode 5 let
us know what you guys think of this
episode in the comment section below and
hey how about that new Godzilla Kong
trailer y'all how do you guys think that
this series will tie into that new movie
let us know let us know but you can find
me at mastertainment on Twitter or
Instagram or wherever I am on the
internet but most importantly do not
forget to follow heavy spoilers here on
YouTube because we always got stuff for
you guys all the time and you don't want
to miss it but again thank you guys so
much you guys are amazing I love you so
much and do good things today go hug
your mom go high-five your dad go give
your siblings the money you owe them
just be good to one another at least in
until the next video okay just do that
for me okay I love you bye